[Music]
welcome back to a next episode of what's
up ruff good day Walter
we are back once more yes with a
continuation of our previous story I'm
looking forward to it when you open up
first thing we can get right into it our
Heavenly Father as we head for the times
that we have been longing for I pray
that you will enlighten our minds and be
with us in our deliberations in Jesus
name Amen yes so you can give us maybe a
quick recap yes we were speaking about
Babylon and the doctrine of the serpent
and we looked at Genesis chapter 3 verse
1 where the serpent said unto the woman
God really say and then he questioned
whether God really said that they
weren't supposed to eat of the fruit and
that you would die she will surely not
die he said this and what was the other
thing that he said you shall be as gods
gods and the third thing he said you
shall know good and evil and then we
looked at the Bible and we looked at all
the places where God said and then the
question is did God really say that do
people still believe that today yes so
we're going into the doctrine of Babylon
and we discussed the first question did
God really say and the woman said God
said that we were not to eat of the tree
in the middle of the garden and the day
you eat of it you will surely die and he
said you will surely not die and we saw
that that is the doctrine of the world
today the world whether it's in
spiritism or in Catholicism or in
Protestantism believes the serpent
rather than God yes I just want to also
say that
the immortality of the soul not merely
means that you live and go to heaven
after you die it also means you go you
can like they say can go to hell either
way it stays immortal if you burn in
hell for always alright still immortal
it's still immortality but God said that
you will die meaning a permanent
obliteration they will consume away like
smoke they will consume away they will
be as though they never were
now the second lie was you shall be as
gods now we know that the New Age
movement preaches that and there are
even books on how to become like Christ
Helen sigma's Chapman's book for example
tells you that you can become Christ but
let's look at this issue again and see
what they teach here's the Catechism of
the Catholic Church this is from Vatican
VI so this is the official web page of
the Roman Catholic Church and article
460 states the following the word became
flesh to make us partakers of the divine
nature now I I don't really have a
problem with that because we have to be
partakers of the divine nature in the
sense that we must emulate God's
character for this is why the word
became man and the Son of God became the
son of man so that man by entering into
communic communion with the word and
thus receiving divine sonship might
become a son of God for the Son of God
became man so that we might become God
that's for the capital G that's an
astounding statement the only begotten
Son of God wanting to make us share
in his divinity assumed our nature so
that he made man might make men gods now
when we look at the New Age movement and
its origins I actually have a lecture on
the New Age movement somewhere then we
can see that the general Jesuits were
also very instrumental in that
particular movement about put it in
incites in total onslaught oh that's
correct yes so is this something that is
just there in the Catechism or is it
something that is further than that who
goes further than that here's an article
and it's quite a recent article it's
from May 13 2016 and it's from zenit
which is a Roman Catholic source and
issue is interview humans become God yes
it's Catholic theology a dozen Catholic
scholars and theologians examine what
the process of deification means in
their respective areas of study the
first generations of Christians saw in
their new lives in Jesus Christ a way to
transcend all the limitations of sin and
death and become new creatures and Peter
expresses this is participating in the
divine nature well said Athanasius
stated it succinctly 300 years later God
became a human so humans could become
God now they will try and rationalize
that but it's very hard to rationalize a
statement like that it's pretty lightly
dafuk ation of humans sounds pretty
new-age could you give us a brief
overview of what this concept means in
Catholic theology now we'll see what
Father
he says far from being new-age
defecation is one of the most ancient
ways of explaining salvation in Jesus
Christ Christianity is a to act play in
the first act God becomes human but that
is just the beginning in the second act
of the play we humans ought to become
like gods is careful in the way it puts
it more loving more joyful incorruptible
and immortal think of a piece of iron
alone it is hard and cold but in a fire
it takes on a new glow a new warmth and
the malleability but it never ceases to
be iron look at section 460 of the
Catechism of the Catholic Church this is
a very central component of Catholicism
the difference between the church's
understanding of deification and the
Mormon doctrine is that Catholics we
believe we become partakers of the
divine nature in Christ but never the
possessors of the Godhead which as far
as I understand it is more in line with
the Mormon view now it's interesting
that the moment view of course was also
influenced by the Jesuit de smet who was
a personal friend of Joseph Smith do you
also have a lecture that it's part of
the New Age movement yes yes correct
let's look at another aspect here
seeking a promotion for the Virgin Mary
the world of today is in desperate need
of a mother whispered professor mark
Miravalle as he sat behind his desk at
Franciscan University in Stephenville
Ohio carefully fingering a string of
rosary beads half of all the wire inside
the Vatican yet another enormous box
arrived filled with petitions asking
pope john paul ii to exercise his
absolute power to proclaim a new and
highly debated dogma that the Virgin
Mary is a
Redeemer with Jesus and cooperates fully
with her son in the redemption of
mankind the title that they wanted for
his co-redemptrix and mediatrix now they
never went that far because they thought
Protestants would have a problem with
this and in the ecumenical climate they
didn't want to up end it so they didn't
go that far but I have newspaper
clippings where it says that Pope John
Paul is not averse to the idea that Mary
can be even part of the Godhead Joe in
German it says I neglected him outta ya
I mean oddly Mary yes correct so this is
rather fascinating so if it applies to
one human content apply to all so in
addition to ordinary Catholics mr.
Morales received support from 550
bishops and 42 Cardinals so you know
what determines whether something
becomes a Dogma or not support by
humanity or the Word of God well it was
according to this of the support by
humanity yes others you have majority
rules correct so it even included
Cardinal John O'Connor and Mother Teresa
before their deaths along the way his
movement has laid bare a deep-seated
conflict between wildly popular devotion
to the Virgin Mary and the efforts of
the established church to keep that
diversion in check although it has the
support of at least twelve Cardinals in
Rome others fear that its acceptance
would cause a major schism amongst
Catholics and setbacks if it's at
ecumenism and the dogma would be an
infallible proclamation by the pub that
would make it truth right according to
them adopted so even if it is contrary
to the Bible it also provoked renewed
debate over the role of the Pope's power
in modern society now Pope John Paul the
second actually has made no sick
of his devotion to Mary and the present
pub exactly the same and the previous
one who rotzinger
totus Tuus which in latin means totally
yours is his motto in which he dedicates
his papacy to her he also credits Mary
with saving his life during 1981
assassination attempt and worth
hastening the fall of communism now
according to the scripture where's Mary
Grave sleeping waiting for the
resurrection so this is rather strange
he has used the phrase co-redemptrix six
times in his papacy to describe Mary
which has led petitioners to hope that
during his lifetime he will proclaim her
co-redeemer so they actually believe it
but for the sake of expediency they
haven't proclaimed it convention the
largest denomination of Protestants in
the United States expressed alarm at the
suggestion that Mary might be a quarry
dema such a worldview is clearly
heretical II said in order to be a
redeemer it would require a person to be
perfect but then of course Rome has
declared the Immaculate Conception that
she was perfect from but now actually
from the moment of conception that she
was totally without sin so how did God
do that by decree now my question is if
God by decree could declare Mary sinless
couldn't he do it for you
yes why is he not doing it for you is
that a selfish act on his the only
convert one person and not to all so is
it biblical no why did he declare Mary
Immaculate and why don't he declare
Jesus as immaculate
yes that's an interesting point to say
they reason that in order for Jesus to
be born out of a human being that person
had
be without sin in order to bring forth
such a redeemer who was immaculate so in
actual fact in Catholic doctrine the
immaculate sinless nature of Jesus is
derived from his mother because she was
immaculate now here's the question
Biko the other the question is now how
do I approach Jesus so the answer is
through Mary she becomes the mediator
and therefore she must be the
co-redemptrix that is their reasoning
but the Bible says that Mary was born
under the law which means under the
condemnation of the Lord she was just
like anyone else so this is an
interesting point we certainly don't
believe she was God some liberal
Protestants have long argued that the
Catholic Church has used the symbol of
Mary to restrict opportunities for women
and as a way of instilling women's
obedience to the teachings of the church
and bishop john Spong one of the most
controversial figures in the episcopal
church now retired says christians need
a feminine symbol for God but that such
a symbol should be created by women not
a bunch of men sitting around in Rome in
their frogs well nevertheless the debate
is interesting but John Paul is on
record as not being averse to the idea
that Mary is divine now what about paper
claims to divinity well of course there
are numerous medieval papal claims they
were called Lord God the Pope what can
you make of me but God said Pope Leo so
there are many many statements where the
pipe papacy has claimed that they are
God's Pope Leo the 13th said these
things about the role of the papacy in
the Roman Church our thoughts went out
towards the immense multitude of those
who are strangers to the gladness that
fold all Catholic hearts some because
they lie in absolute ignorance of the
gospel other
because they descent from Catholic
belief though they bear the name of
Christians this thought has been and is
a source of deep concern to us
capitalized remember God said let us
capitalize
make man in our image so by capitalizing
it they are applying deity to themselves
for it is impossible to think of such a
large portion of mankind deviating as it
were from the right path as they move
away from us and not experience a
sentiment of innermost grief but since
we hold upon the earth the place of God
Almighty that's a fascinating statement
here's another one from Publio but the
supreme teacher in the church is the
Roman pontiff union of minds therefore
requires together with a perfect Accord
in the one faith complete submission and
obedience of will to the church and to
the roman pontiff as to God himself now
what is the Roman pontiff teach us
something which is diametrically opposed
to what the Bible teaches then I have to
choose who I'm worshipping right yes
more recently Pope John Paul the second
wrote that names like holy father or
applicable to the Pope even though
calling him that is counter to the
gospel I think we should read the quote
out of this book I happen to have his
book crossing the threshold of house and
it's on page 6 this quote and he writes
returning to your question I would like
to recall the words of Christ together
with my first words in st. Peter's
Square be not afraid
have no fear when people call me the
of Christ when they say to me Holy
Father or your holiness or use titles
similar to these which seemed even
inimical to the gospel of Christ himself
declared call no one on earth your
father you have but one Father in heaven
do not be called master you have but one
master the messiah matthew 23:9 2:10
that's astounding he says don't oppose
it it's right they can call me that even
though it's against the Bible Jesus
endured these expressions nevertheless
have evolved out of a long tradition
becoming a part of common usage one must
not be afraid of these words either so
you shouldn't be afraid if the Bible
condemns it because tradition upholds it
so who is higher the Bible or tradition
well in their ranks
absolutely in 1996 he also gave his
assent to calling the Pope Lord and
Christ on earth we read readily
understand that the version of st.
Francis of Assissi for the Lord Pope the
daughter Lee outspokenness of st.
Catherine of Siena towards the one whom
she called sweet Christ on earth the
apostolic obedience and the Cynthia come
ecclesia of st. ignatius loyola the
jesuit father and the joyful profession
of faith made by Saint Teresa of ávila I
am a daughter of the church so the
papacy clearly has no problem with
deifying the general populace but
particularly themselves he's the title
Pontifex Maximus does that have anything
to do with the title Pontifex Maximus
who was the original
title of the Babylonian priesthood and
when the medo-persians conquered Babylon
then the Babylonian priesthood fled to
pergamus and there they established a
separate Kingdom a priestly God Kingdom
where the high priest had the title
Pontifex Maximus and he was worshipped
as God God it's interesting and the
interesting thing is that the metre
person's never conquered that city
neither did the Greeks and the Romans
they never conquered it in a war but the
last king of Babylon priest king who had
the title Pontifex Maximus was king at
talus and he bequeathed his title and
everything that goes with it
to the Roman Emperor and the Roman
emperors never appropriated it they they
used the title but they didn't you
didn't defy themselves until you get to
Julius Caesar this is where the title
Caesar comes from and Julius Caesar had
himself crowned as a reincarnation of of
the god of Paulo and he was to be
defined and from that day on they had
the title Pontifex Maximus and they were
gods and they had to be worshipped so
there were temples erected for the
Caesars and everybody had to worship the
Caesar the early Christians refused and
so they were thrown to the Lions and to
the gladiators and they were crucified
and eventually when Rome then started
dissipating and the Roman pontiff took
the title so the Bishop of Rome took the
title Pontifex and its powers so he
became a god and that title today is
those
it's with the Pope it is the rich loop
title of the king of Babylon so in other
words anyone who has that title is the
king of Babylon and the Pope has it yes
interesting is Twitter account is at
Pontifex ah that's interesting I didn't
know that so what was the third lie of
the serpent that you in your own
strength would be able to determine
right and wrong you know in good and
evil
here's article three of the Catechism of
the Catholic Church God created man a
rational being conferring on him the
dignity of a person who can initiate and
control his own actions
God well that man should be left in the
hands of his own counsel so that he
might of his own accord seek his creator
and freely attained his full Blessed
perfection by cleaving to him
the Bible says nobody seeks God here
they say you seek God by yourself so the
Bible says now God searches for you the
Catholic Church says no you search for
God
this is the master of reversal
everything is reversed
here's an interesting article from the
story of Protestantism by oldest I'm gay
it's a very famous book on Protestantism
and it tells us that this debate even
raged in the time of Martin Luther
already became one of the points of
dispute it was john egg now Chancellor
of the University of Ingolstadt had
attacked Luther's opinion in a work
entitled the obelisks to this account
the pamphlet had been issued by Andrew
Bernstein andreas bodenstein in German
better known as Col stud who was now
challenged by egg to one of those public
dispute ations which played no mean part
controversy in the days when there was
no newspaper press but before the day
fixed for the disputation arrived X must
needs published 13 theses in which he
plainly attacked Luther and thus the
professor self thought bonds were loose
and Luther himself was drawn into the
war of words with egg-wich weights that
light see in july 1519 and at the issue
the disputation is important for it
marks a distinct stage and the drawing
of the line between Rome and the
Reformers the question of free will was
first debated dr. Eck and his friends
maintained that man without the aid of
the Holy Spirit and simply of himself
has the power to choose what is
spiritually good there's the Catholic
doctrine and two about God Luther and
constant on the other hand contended
that until his nature is renewed by the
spirit man cannot love and serve God
nobody seeks God says the body yeah but
you know what they say but we have to
find it in modern theology right yes
because this is important because
remember what we were discussing we were
discussing what is Babylon and why do we
have to flee from Babylon and we were
discussing the components of Babylon
there was the dragon which is spiritism
yes there was the Beast which is
Catholicism and then there's the false
prophet which arises out of the USA so
it is Protestantism that has returned to
its Babylonian miss origins so this is
what Martin Luther believed then yes who
you want to get to the root of it and
see how it's a precursor
yeah there's no evidence here that
Protestantism is part of Babylon the
only thing that is part of Babylon at
this stage is the dragon who's the devil
himself and spiritism through his
spirits and Catholicism but there's no
evidence that Protestantism
involved now this is a quote from
Richard M gula recently informed by
faith now he is a Jesuit teacher so this
is what the Jesuits believe remember
when a Jesuit publishes something it is
on behalf of the jaleswar general
because he may do nothing without the
consent of his Jesuit general so this is
the idea of the Roman Catholic Church at
its core so what does he say since
vatican ii a significant broad consensus
on moral theological literature suggests
that the human person is the most
appropriate point of departure for
elaborating on the meaning of morality
in general and for providing the
fundamental criteria which are necessary
for dealing with specific moral
questions so you don't start with
Scripture you start with man to say that
the person adequately considered is the
norm of morality does not be throw God
and raise the human person to the level
of the supreme values that's he adds as
an afterthought but let's see how it
continues what it's always bound to
follow the judgment of a properly
informed conscience the informing takes
place in community given our interest is
by appealing to the various sources of
moral wisdom various sources in the
church where's the moral criterion in
the church in the church the Magisterial
is the source of moral authority now
what is the Magisterial that's the Pope
and his bishops the hierarchy of the
church they will determine what is right
it's teaching is very important they are
not exclusive factor in the formation of
conscience and in one's moral judgment
then he says there's
appeal to authority is part of
responsible living in appealing to an
authority Authority we believe that it
will be more correct about this question
than we will so the moral authority will
be more correct than we are or than
anyone else to whom we might appeal so
if I want to know what is morally right
I have to ask the church not the Bible
the church no and it takes place in
community which means the community can
for me what is right so if a certain
lifestyle which is contrary to the Bible
is acceptable in the community then that
becomes the moral value and not the
Bible
hmmm however the great advantages over
having an institutionalized authority in
the Magisterium is that it provides a
structure which can bring together in a
cooperative and complimentary way the
experience and insights of various
perspective so as to reach as complete
an expression of truth about moral life
as possible so where do you determine
the truth in the Magisterium where does
the Bible say do you determine the truth
in the world
thy Word is truth Jesus says I am the
way the truth and the life all thy
commandments are truth truth okay can
you see a conflict developing here yes
well then the midst of so many
conflicting voices telling us what to do
in so many diverse communities
projecting images of what makes life
worthwhile we are fortunate to have the
Magisterium to teach in moral matters
the primary responsibility of the
Magisterium is to help us to understand
the gospel for our times and to foster
our simulation of its basic values the
formula now infallible decision
conscience decides is a complete
distortion of the real function of
conscience
needs to be informed for Catholics to
make a decision of conscience with
indifference to or in spite of the
Magisterium would be forfeiting once
claimed to be acting as a loyal Catholic
and according to a probably informed
conscience so in other words you have to
make all your moral decisions through
the thinking of the hierarchy of the
church so actually your conscience is
dictated by them right now the name of
this book is interesting to me is author
of many books the the name of the book
is Reason informed by faith now what is
higher reason or faith in this equation
if your reason
is informed by faith then your reason is
higher than your faith right so they put
human reason above faith but faith can
inform your reason according to this
target now if I had to make a scriptural
title then I would reverse it I would
say faith informed by reason because the
Bible says faith is the highest one
because without faith it is impossible
to please God
rightness so faith must be the first
objective faith in what faith in God's
words faith in Jesus Christ is my
Redeemer that is the first thing and
that sits the parameter and my reason
can inform my faith but it cannot uproot
my faith with faith you'll accept God
really said correct and then reason will
bring into that otherwise when you put a
reason on top then you can say that God
really saying yes very good point very
good point so the judgment of conscience
properly formed takes seriously that we
are limited in our
experience and vision of what is good
but that we can learn from the broader
experience and vision to which we belong
the official teaching of the Magisterium
can open us to that broader experience
and provide that broader vision the key
text for understanding a loyal response
to Magisterial teaching is in lumen
gentium so it's a papal encyclical what
does it say in matters of faith and
morals
the Bishop's speak in the name of Christ
and the faithful except except their
teaching and adhere to it with religious
assent of soul that means I agree what
it says I will do this religious
submission of will and of mind must be
shown in a special way to the authentic
teaching authority of the Roman pontiff
even when he is not speaking ex cathedra
oh okay that means that if the Pope says
something I will set my mind aside and
accept what he says yes I will become
brain-dead now this is a Jesuit speaking
and the Jesuit oath says that even well
not the earth but one of the statements
is that even if God should give you a
dog as a general you would not refuse to
obey Him yes what is that statement it
Kodama and khaddama yeah yeah in other
words you will obey like the corpse it's
like a corpse you will have no mind of
your own now did God ever bypass our
freedom of choice you know he came
that's why he died for us
ah huh why did Jesus die so that we can
have freedom of choice yes he could have
forced us he could have made us slaves
like this and told us you will obey and
I'll be the puppet master now he wants
woeful obedient by choice
so the question is what does religious
ascent of submission of will and mind
mean in moral matters this is Richard
gula asking the question not me
religious assent or submission this
teaching means that such effort and
appropriation or motivated by the
conviction that Jesus has commissioned
the church to teach and that the Spirit
Guides the church in truth Francis a
Sullivan and ecclesiology from the
Gregorian University of Rome so in areas
quote one Jesuit quoting another Jesuit
has analyzed this expression in his
masterful work Magisterium teaching
Authority and the Catholic Church and
offers the summary statement of its
meaning as I understand it then to give
the required obsequious Relic Yoshio now
we get the word obsequious from this now
what is the word obsequious mean it
means to be totally submissive in
religious matter totally submissive in
religious matter to the teaching of the
ordinary Magisterium means to make an
honest and sustained effort to overcome
any contrary opinion I might have and to
achieve a sincere assent of mind to a
middle position has been expressed in
the official text of the 1978 national
catechetical directory sharing the light
of faith in other words it is the task
of the catechesis to elicit assent to
agree to in all the church teachers so
if the Bible says you will die and the
church says you will not die you must
believe the church for the church is the
indispensable guide to the complete
richness of what Jesus teaches when
faced with a question which pertained to
descent from non infallible teachings of
the churches is important for the
catechist to keep in mind that the
Samson is always in favor of the
Magisterium so if I have a contrary
opinion I better change it Vatican 2
taught us the proper relationship of
conscience of Magisterial Authority and
moral matters in the way it affirmed the
primacy of conscience a particular
significant position is found in the
Declaration on religious freedom where
we read in the formation of our
consciences the Christian faithful ought
carefully to attend to the sacred and
certain doctrine of the church an
earlier ending of this text read or to
form their conscience according to the
teachings of the church the rendering
according to was rejected for being
overly restrictive conclusion the
Catholic preference in wanting to be
guided by an expert or voice of
authority is to turn to the Magisterium
although now external Authority can ever
replace conscience conscience cannot be
properly formed without the help of
authority now who is that Authority well
the Magisterium you the majesty element
who is the head of the Magisterium the
Pope and he's the only one who speaks is
fallible II infallibly so here you have
the whole Kabang do you have knowing
good and evil conscience so let's go to
the present general of the Jesuits and
ask him how he sees the function of the
Society of Jesus
what is the Commission according to the
Bible of anyone who follows Jesus Christ
to make disciples of other people go ye
into all the world and teach preach
that'll preach the gospel every tongue
and tribe and nation okay what is the
gospel it's the good news of salvation
let's see what their good news is to
show the way to God through the
Spiritual Exercises
and discernment so the spiritual
exercises are exercises as we have to
sky
in previous ones where basically you
open your mind to the spirit world and
your communication where the spirit
world becomes natural and you must use
all your senses you must use your sense
of smell your sense of sight so you
imagine yourself in a position and then
you actually move in your imagination
into that position so that all your
senses become affected you put yourself
in a situation you smell how it is going
here and if you go to the history of
Protestantism then you will see that
this is recorded by the historians of
Protestantism that the difference
between Jesuit theology and biblical
theology is that the one is based on
spiritism which is dragon theology
because you are actually communicating
and it becomes a reality but faith is
the substance of things hoped for the
evidence of things not seen and now it
becomes very dangerous it's exceedingly
dangerous when you get to biblical exit
they put the disguise of the biblical
exercises on top of this and then what
becomes the norm the scripture or the
experience well most of the time they
experience virtually all the time
because it's a distorted explanation
they use meditation yes babbling we have
Christian meditation but actually it's
another form of Spiritual Exercises it's
a spiritual exercise meditation in the
biblical sense is studying the Word of
God and assessing the meaning of what
God is saying and praying that God will
enlighten your mind through the Holy
Spirit not in this situation so the
spiritual exercises are exactly that
spiritism there are dragon theology to
walk with the poor the our cost of the
world those whose dignity has been
violated in
mission of reconciliation and justice so
this is social justice the gospel is to
go to part of the world or the whole
world and the whole world yes the poor
will be more likely to accept it because
they haven't got that many strings
attached in them to this world that the
gospel has to go to everyone and to
accompany young people in the creation
of our full future does the gospel
differentiate between young and old the
Jesus have a differentiated twist
between young and old did he separate
them at his meetings did he tell them to
march for a particular cause it's just
interesting the these points that you've
mentioned now comes from the general of
the Jesuits yes but if you remember the
previous episode we had the document of
Jubilee for the earth yes that was put
up by Protestants and that was full of
Spiritual Exercises and young people all
of us was the rioting or no sorry that
protest tasty I see okay and then to
collaborate in the care of our home so
this is the gospel to perform
spiritualistic exercises of Loyola which
will separate you from God they are not
from God they are from another source
because eventually just a simple example
if in your spiritual exercises you feel
that there is no need to keep all the
commandments for instance and you've
been shown through this exercises that
there is truth then you go with that and
what if you have discussions with
Catholic saints that come to you during
your spiritualistic experience and your
ecstasy what if Mary appears to you what
is said whoever appears to you the
battle says those people are asleep
waiting in the dust for the resurrection
then who are you talking to you're
talking to a demon exactly now my other
question is on these four points over
here where is the gospel of Jesus Christ
no way is it anyway I cannot see it
anywhere
they've even got on the fourth point
your God I will change climate change
climate change quiet mother earth yeah
this there's no gospel of Jesus Christ
here so how they can call themselves the
Society of Jesus is beyond me then he
says they are not preferences we have
followed the Holy Spirit which Holy
Spirit definitely not the Holy Spirit of
the Bible it must be one of those other
birds yes that the Bible referred to who
has guided and inspired us we received
them confirmed by the Pope
trusting like ik Nazis and the first
companions that he is the one who has
the best vision of the needs of the
world and of the church in other words
the one who will tell me what is right
and what is wrong and has the best needs
of the world and of the church at heart
is the Pope the universal apostolic
preferences will help us to overcome
every form of self-centeredness and
corporatism so that women become of
authentic collaborators in the Lord's
mission which Lord the Lord Pope or the
Lord Jesus Christ which we share with so
many people inside and outside the
church the preferences are an
opportunity for us to feel that we are
the least Society in collaboration with
others it sounds so humble but there is
no gospel if we go to this book Babylon
the Great there are some interesting
quotes as to how people viewed the the
Jesuit Order and here is a statement in
this book the secret Illuminati
organization was hidden guiding hand by
and the brutal French Revolution and we
are on the verge of a new revolution in
our time a lot of the people in America
actually in the articles and news
articles and so on like there's a lot of
mentioning that this is like a social
revolution and it's like the French
Revolution during which three hundred
thousand people were massacred in a
godless orgy of violence the rage by the
Jesuits and their reconstituted
Illuminati culminated in 1798 with the
capture of the Pope himself Napoleon's
general birthday invaded Rome took the
Pope Pius the sixth prisoner and held
him until his death now the Roman
Catholic Church there for a while banned
the Jesuits but they paid a heavy price
for it and then the Roman Church had
learned it's lesson and in eighteen
hundred and fourteen the Jesuits were
restored as a Catholic order by Pope
Pius the seventh by the way with the
proclamation that they may never be
banned again interesting is John Adams
wrote to Thomas Jefferson in 1816 I'm
not happy about the rebirth of the
Jesuits swarms of them will present
themselves and the more disguises ever
taken by even the chief of the Bohemians
as printers writers publishers
schoolteachers etc if ever an
association of people deserved eternal
damnation on this earth and in hell it
is the Society of Loyola yet with our
system of religious liberty we can but
offer them a refuge Thomas Jefferson
answered Adams like you I object to the
Jesuits establishment which makes light
give way to darkness if you think of all
the Jesuit colleges in the United States
alone these days then these words have
certainly come true yes and it's
actually surprising that we have
prominent people that try and detect
and say okay this guy's this one this
person studied there but that doesn't
necessarily make him a Jesuit no want
you to decide if he's a Jesuit why would
you want to go to an institution that's
going to feed you with poison if you
know this is what they like they're
going to teach you exactly now it's
interesting that they come under many
disguises printers writers publishers
schoolteachers
what about Protestants haven't they
infiltrated Protestant churches why are
Protestant churches today preaching the
Ignasi and theology obviously they've
lost the plot if they can write
documents like that document we
discussed last time yes then they have
become part of Babylon in 1835 Samuel
Moss the great inventor of the Telegraph
echoed the concerns concerns of
Jefferson and Adams he described the
Jesuits and their threat to the United
States as follows and do Americans need
to be told what Jesuits are if any are
ignorant let them inform themselves of
their history without delay no time is
to be lost their workings are before you
in everyday events they are a secret
society a sort of Masonic Order with
super added features of the most
revolting odious nests and a thousand
times more dangerous they are not
confined to one class in society they
are not merely priests or priests of one
religious creed you see they infiltrate
others they are merchants and lawyers
and editors and men of any profession
and no profession having no output badge
in this country by which to be
recognized they are about in all your
society they can assume any character
that of Angels of Light or ministers of
darkness to accomplish their one great
and the service upon which they are
sworn to start at any moment in any
direction and for any service commanded
by the general of their order bound to
no family community or country by the
ordinary tires which by men and sold for
life to the cause of the Roman pontiff
we have Jesuit theology everywhere the
churches are preaching it in the
ecumenical movement it is being
practiced we should according to the
scripture have nothing to do with this
come out of her my people so my next
question would be how does this
influence the use of Scripture pre
critical use of Scripture
this is Richard in gula speaking again
the Catholic moral tradition has laid
claim to two sources for acquiring moral
knowledge scripture and natural law so
they acknowledge Scripture as natural
law but now because it has been so
concerned with finding a common ground
for moral life with all people which all
people could endorse Catholic tradition
has given prominence to natural law as
the primary sources of moral knowledge
so not what the scripture says is
important what is important is what is
moral value in society natural natural
law what occurs naturally amongst
peoples even if they have no scriptures
that's more important than the
scriptures so you don't go and do what
the Bible says make disciples of men and
teach them when I became a Protestant
and I called the Catholic priests to my
house and I said could you please
explain this to me in the Bible why do
you people say this and this and the
Bible says his words were and he was a
Catholic priest
learn into Scripture it solved it for me
while it gives the appearance of a
biblical grounding to moral theology
proof texting really does not allow
scripture to enter the fabric of moral
theological reflection scripture has no
part in it this is Roman Catholic
teaching now my question can we say that
this is a Christian institution no no
you can you cannot it's not a Christian
institution we'll see later why it's not
Christian because it denies every tenet
of the Bible everyone so that you
scripture where it suits them but
sideline it everywhere else because of
their being subject to historical
conditioning biblical texts must be
interpreted in order to be applied to
contemporary situations in other words
the scripture is not the same yesterday
today and forever if it said something
in the past
well then might mean something else
today is so god it's not a god of
consistency no it was written for that
time today we're living in modern times
it should be adjusted
is this taking your own way to heaven
yes is this Babylonian yes anybody who
follows this becomes a Babylonian
are you a part of Babylon that document
that we read yes it was a particular was
a Babylonian definitely Babylonian so
when the Bible says come out of Babylon
what does that mean you must leave that
system system and all the teachings now
here's this interesting exegetical task
the exegetical task seeks to determine
what the text meant in its original
setting what does it mean then doesn't
paul at the same reality in mind when he
condemns homosexuality as we have in
mind
when we use the
in the light of our understanding of
psychology and anthropology okay so who
will determine what it means Paul or our
understanding of the issue in the light
of present-day psychology and
anthropology what becomes the norm the
psychology and anthropology not the
Scriptures this is not biblical
so in this exegetical way if it doesn't
apply the same today in our
understanding of things then it's not
you reject the object you reject the
Bible doesn't mean anything so the Bible
is what might as well put it on yourself
or use it as a doorstop right as a
result we need to be modest about the
claims we make when appealing to the
Bible in moral reflection in other words
forget it then he talks about the
magnetical task
I mean ethical seeks to establish the
meaning of the text for today
aha that's so much nicer because now I
can just circumvent God for example we
do not live consciously waiting for the
imminent end of the world excuse me why
not I am living and waiting for the end
of the world but they are not why not
because they understanding of the word
doesn't need them to be waiting for it
right now Jesus Christ said that the
place of help of the church is the
second coming Catholicism teaches a
millennion ISM these new millennium
doesn't exist says so in the Bible but
who cares right
so a millennialism means there is no
millennium so what is this kingdom that
we're waiting for the kingdom that they
are waiting for is when the church rules
now that's the same kingdom that the
Jews were waiting for they were waiting
for the kingdom where they would be
rulers of the world but the kingdom that
we are waiting for is the kingdom where
God is the ruler of
yes so we're on opposite page here if
you believe the Bible you are waiting
for the coming of Christ that is the
place at Hope I go to prepare a place to
you for you and when I go I I will come
again to take you in my father's are so
many mansions if it were not so I would
have told you I go to prepare a place
for you and when I go I will come again
to take you away I and also that's the
place of hope but now these people say
we're not interested
this eschatological view influences the
way we interpret the radical demands of
Jesus proclamation of the right of God
you see they believes the church will
reign and I believe Jesus Christ will
reign a big difference and then also and
now what is it Protestants say well it's
interesting that Martin Luther and the
the Lutheran Church like the Catholics
or a Millennials they inherited it it's
a it's an Augustinian doctrine so Martin
Luther was an Augustinian monk so he
hadn't he hadn't realized this yet
and then Hans hood remember yes Hans
hood he discovered in the time of the
reformers that Christ would come before
the Millenium and take his people away
and then rule so the Protestants and the
Catholics were opposed to that doctrine
and Protestants actually killed Hans
would yeah and they burnt his bones just
like the Catholics had done to Wickliffe
yes and the interesting thing is this
theology of the millennium and the
coming of Christ remained a dispute many
of the evangelicals believed in the
reign of Christ down here and all the
nations down here get a second chance
so this is the great millennial hope
that everybody was waiting for
but the Millerites thought no
there will be a coming of Christ the
destruction of the wicked the
translation of the the living in Christ
and the resurrection of the dead in
Christ and they will be taken according
to the scripture to meet the Lord in the
air and go for the Millenium but these
people don't believe it and the
evangelicals don't believe as the
Catholics but they also don't believe as
the Bible believes so what is the
theological task often in Catholic
circles the biblical foundations and
Theological presuppositions of a moral
position have gone unexpressed in favor
of a natural law argument what happens
naturally in nature is fine so if you
for example have a society where
whatever happens in terms of marriage
relations or whatever whatever that norm
is that applies not what the scripture
says one extreme would make scripture
the sole source of moral wisdom and
discount any other the Catholic
tradition has never endorsed this
position okay so in other words are they
for or against the scripture against it
all Scripture is god-breathed right and
is for correction and teaching and all
of these things but here it is plainly
rejected so if you are one of those
people that say no the Bible is my main
source of morality and or the only
source of morality then you are extreme
absolutely your next you must and you
are against the Magisterium what was the
punishment for being against the
Magisterium and the good old days of of
Catholic rule burned at the stake
exactly you're a heretic I want to be
the future punishment the same the same
in my treatment of formation of
conscience I pointed out that character
is formed in community by committing our
freedom to a particular object of
loyalty you commit your freedom to a
particular object of loyalty later on e
defines that object of loyalties of
course the Pope and went by
internalizing the images the rituals the
traditions etc which the community has
fashioned in order to carry the meaning
attached to that object of loyalty
that's where you find your moral compass
I reject this with every fiber of my
being to me the moral compass is the
word of God and like Martin Luther I
want to say here I stand I can do no
other here's another book of his moral
discernment where we're not going to
read at all
it just says shows that conscience is
not a law unto itself but must be formed
in community by appealing to the sources
of moral wisdom so this is where the
issue of common good comes yums and
that's where the first time they
mentioned community yeah this was
related so in other words the Pope has
clearly said well the papacy has clearly
said that your freedom of religion is
totally subject to the common good so if
the common good defines something which
is contrary to the Bible then the common
good takes precedence over the Bible
this is a dangerous issue so really
Catholicism doesn't give you freedom of
religion so if you go back to the French
Revolution what did the community decide
there yes that God should be taken right
out of the picture yes and now they this
Cathedral that stood for that travesty
of justice where they enthroned the
goddess of reasons a reason of reason
over the Bible that one that down and
now it has to be restored at great
expense why do they want to enthrone
reason again so they can be destroyed
again I'm wondering not that I will
destroy it I'll wait for God to do it so
let's look at some of the examples
amongst thousands 1 Timothy 4 verse 1
now the spirit speaks expressly that in
the latter times some shall depart from
the faith giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of devils now if
you want to know what the Reformers
believe about this text then you can go
to Romanism and the Reformation by
grattan-guinness that's Church of
England so that's not Adventism and they
will spell it out for you very clearly
who the Reformers thought - supplied to
it applied to Roman Catholicism I want
to make something very plain when I say
Roman Catholicism I'm not talking about
Catholics I'm sure that 99% of Catholics
don't know anything about this deeper
teaching of Roman Catholicism if they
knew they would be as appalled as was
Martin Luther and the same with the
Protestants that's your showing how you
can be part of Babylon without knowing
that even knowing it absolutely so he
qualifies it by continuing speaking lies
in hypocrisy we've just dealt with a lot
of lies having their conscience seared
with a hot iron they're not even ashamed
of it forbidding to marry
commanding to abstain from meats foods
in other words which God has created to
be received with Thanksgiving of them
which believe and know the truth okay so
this organization that he's referring to
that is preaching the doctrines of
devils I mean this is called serpentine
the slaked arrived and we've seen the
southern theology in the official
documents of the Roman Catholic Church
so they're speaking lies because the
devil told the lives jesus said that
ever was a liar from the beginning and
he was a murderer from the beginning
he's the father of lies
having their conscience seared as with a
hot iron they don't even bother about it
forbidding to marry which ecclesiastical
body for bets its ecclesia to marry the
Roman Catholic Church so this applies to
the Roman Catholic Church commanding to
abstain from foods meats which God has
created to be received with Thanksgiving
which ecclesiastical body has instituted
specific fast days like lent for example
Romana the Roman Catholic Church or in
the old days when they enforce the
abstinence of meat other than fish on a
Friday etc etc etc this is not to convey
confused with the health message nothing
to do with the health message this is
criteria of the doctrines of devils
I mean God gave a health message
obviously that's not a doctrine of
Devil's right now this has to do with an
ecclesiastical mindset where they lie to
you where their conscience is totally
seared because they accept any norms of
society above that of the Bible they
forbid the ecclesia to marry and they
can command feast days and fast days
according to their women let's take
another example 1 Corinthians 9:27 the
King James Version here says but I keep
under my body and bring it into
subjection lest by any means when I've
preached to others i myself should be a
castaway so what what Paul is saying is
I
have control over my body I will
determine what goes into my mouth I will
determine what comes out of my mouth I
will determined how I deal with my
sexuality I am in command I always put
it succinctly and say God put the head
on the top
everything else is love that is lower
than the head is subservient to the head
but now look how the NIV based on of
course the manuscripts that they sole of
place states it no I strike a blow to my
body you never said that you said I keep
undone my body I keep it in subjection
to my mind but no you know it says I
strike a blow to my body and make it my
slave so that after I have preached to
others i myself will not be disqualified
for the prize
oh yes the world English Bible but I
beat my body and bring it into
submission for fear that by any means
that after I've preached to others i
myself should be rejected or here in 1
Corinthians 9:27 I chastise my body this
is the dua rhymes the jesuits Bible I
chastise my body and bring it into
subjection etc so this is in line with
what we've seen that they will actually
change the Bible in order to suit their
doctrine so do they do this
absolutely why did some Catholics
self-flagellating selves in these
rituals until they are bleeding and the
magazine answers is the BBC news the
late pope john paul ii would whipped
himself according to a nun who helped to
look after him so how common is this
practice and the Catholic faith Martin
Luther when he was a Catholic used to
beat himself and this is not biblical
but this is how you can distort the
scripture then it becomes a salvation by
I know where did God require this from
anyone nowhere in the scripture now the
most serious one as far as I'm concerned
is the issue of the atonement you know
what the issue of the atonement is such
an important issue it's the very heart
of the gospel it's the plan of salvation
I think we should discuss that in
another session yes I agree with you so
let's pray pray Heavenly Father thank
you so much for this wonderful
discussion we pray that you bless all
the viewers and all the listeners and
also bring us together again for another
discussion in Jesus name Amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click here when the PAL
appears click again to get notifications
to watch the next video click here thank
you